alors maintenant on va passer à une
nouvelle interview qui s'appelle
l'interview mensonge
voilà bonne idée bonne élève
alors alors sip
voilà le principe c'est pas obligé de
répondre le contraire de la question
mais en tous les cas on ne répond pas la
vérité à mentir il faut mentir c'est
l'interview tiberi on aurait pu
l'appeler par exemple un d'accord je
vois leur attention les bacs servira
beaucoup de charme xavier a beaucoup de
charme
alors est ce que laurent tu as déjà
trompé sa femme tous les jours tous les
shows est-ce que tu trouve ça trop cher
les prostituées écoute non parce que
j'en ai quelques jeunes qui travaillent
pour moi et comme ça me rapporte non je
trouve ces jeunes ou trop chères donc tu
as bien compris que nous apprend on ne
garde que les réponses bien entendu pour
l'épauler compiler tous à bien entendre
les bêtisiers qui font le bonheur de la
télévision comme on l'a encore vu ce
soir sur france 2 tu fréquentes toujours
les boîtes échangistes toujours toujours
c'est une passion chez moi ouais j'ai
commencé à sept ans et demi ce qui est
pas évident pour rentrer et de se
déguiser obligés d'y passer pour un 1 de
43 ans beaucoup de maquillage et puis tu
sais l'un dans l'autre on s'y fait comme
on dit c'est toujours ça c'est thierry
siquet là je suis en effet change pas
croire qu il change alors il change de
nom
comme cette question là les patients le
segment des sorties qui savait ce qui
t'as fait ça c'est un meurtre je crois
que leur faut passer à un autre
décorateur nouvelle émission laurent ya
un bout de contreplaqué qui restent
vivent certains biens comme gardant bien
tu vends l'émission on avait beaucoup de
thunes
c'est chiant à présent plus une question
qui revient avec le sexe est ce que tu
utilises des capotes
tous les jours elle serait ce que pour
cuisiner je n'ai pas confiance dans les
aliments transgéniques la génitrice et
ligne top100 souvent donc tous les jours
les jours alors maintenant être encore
plus obscène linda on va parler encore
plus
benoît renouveau une méthode déjà au
bout de deux semaines
alors on va être encore plus obscène on
va parler de télévision ton animateurs
favori de l'eau ben moi je suis un peu
comme vous la semaine dernière j'aime
bien
comment s'appelle-t-il sabatier ouais
et puis j'avais une grande tendresse et
une grande admiration pour celui qui
paie de la radio maintenant qui faisait
tout est possible à comment il
s'appelait su quitter tout est possible
bon ni morandi j'aimais bien aussi
je veux un peu oublié les noms des gens
que j'aimais bien c'est lui qui truquent
de roswell pradel j'aime beaucoup
l'intégrité journalistique j'aime
beaucoup le
le vrai contact et je n'aime pas le
voyeurisme les un chantre h et je trouve
que c'est des gens qui ont apporté
beaucoup à la télé c'est bien c'est bien
est ce que tu penses qu'on pourra
remplacer dorothée la télévision lors
non non ne serait ce que pour des
millions d'enfants il faut pas le faire
j'adore cet argument les pires en plein
essor à lire en page un petit peu
d'accord alors est ce que tu as déjà
couché pour du boulot c'était mon boulot
que de coucher énervé lorsque vous avez
longtemps dit qu'il fallait à la télé
fait les mains mouillées dans les
couloirs mais alors attendez d'un côté
je suis viré de partout j'ai plus de
boulot d'un côté si je dis la vérité
j'ai pu en retrouver oui j'ai couché
avec hervé bourges ça vous va non mais
ça on avait dit qu'on allait pas voilà
donc c'est quelque chose pas diffusable
est ce que tu gagnes bien ta vie leur
écoute
il ya des hauts il ya des bas mais
je la gagne pas assez à mon goût non
mais par rapport à un ouvrier de chez
renault je trouve scandaleuses le blé
qui peut emmener chez lui par rapport à
moi ouais
en refaisant mécaniquement toujours le
même geste alors que moi quand je fasse
preuve d' inventions de 2,2 je trouve qu
une échelle de valeur qui est pas bien
acceptés là est ce que tu penses être un
exemple pour résumer cela oui oui oui et
je comprends pas pourquoi on me casse
les couilles et des bustes de marianne
dans les mairies les écoles et là ils
attendent que je sois chauffe pour vous
tirer le portrait faire un budget c'est
quoi le le premier qui marche bien entre
vous c'est qu'il vous fait toujours il
ya toujours derrière ma laurent ben oui
un peu de gens comme ça le rend m'a
toujours fait rire bien sûr toujours
cette fois les gens en deuil j'ai un
petit endroit c'est pour ça que j'ai
pour ça qu'on vit ensemble ainsi du coup
bah oui le matin quand je me tiens là la
pêche et plaisir laurent je m'en fous je
dis ça est-ce que tu trouve ça bien de
mentir je trouve ça affligeant comme
interview est pourquoi les jaf est
convenu
ouais non je suis toujours le truc là
j'arrive et même dans cette affaire j'ai
fait pour moi j'étais pris à mon propre
piège je me disais mais pourquoi moi
j'adore cette idée là très bien comment
le lot non merci alors il y aura un
calot borloo une blonde à forte poitrine
eh bien
[Applaudissements]
pas trop on se voit un frère voilà tu
restes là toi ouais bon bah ça va alors
ça vous convient et mac
arrivé tout retourné bon alors
maintenant on va passer à l'interview
mensonges et j'aimerais serge combelles
s'intitule à lui attention images fixes
vous ne bougez plus voilà alors elie
semoun l'interview mensonger comme
d'habitude à la télévision les
interviews vous répondez par des
mensonges c'est tout à fait habituel
j'imagine qu'à la télé tous les cas les
gens voilà elie semoun est ce que vous
souhaitez toujours tout ce qui bouge
non ça m'est arrivé dernièrement c'était
quand j'étais à l'école tu vas arrêter
tout ce qu'il vous questions difficiles
de madame belber de la chan est ce que
vous êtes toujours de droite
oui oui plus que jamais ouais j'avais
l'extrême droite extrême député du front
national du
de la région de dreux 1 présente contre
dieudonné est ce que vous êtes toujours
antisémite est dit c'est à dire c'est un
petit peu énervant là j'ai l'impression
qu'ils avaient quelqu'un qui me touche
enfin la force de chercher les blondes à
fortes oui c'est normal ça peut vous
arriver
alors je suis je suis antisémite ou et
je déteste les juifs
attention là il a un début d'érection
mais vous allez faites attention parce
qu'après il se contrôle plus ses jours
dans la finesse
ouais comme manger des péloche ou quoi
comment vous trouvez linda hardy
c'est un boudin c'est une fin de série
c1 ces mensonges des manceaux et vous
comment vous trouvez les visites mans
très beau est ce que vous avez donné
pour le téléthon pourquoi il ya
quelqu'un à chaque fois derrière qui
fait là haut
comme si les gens pouvaient pas réagir
normalement ce qu'il vous trouve beau ah
oui mais pas celle que je viens viens
auguste chauffeur de salle à ses
chauffeurs de savoir où tu sais toi en
fait qui a oui voilà la robuste il un
truc génial enrichit sa formidable quand
il veut que les gens applaudissent il
fait ça les i
voila voila c'est la télé c'est
vachement à la télé c'est un truc super
spontanée quand même c'est génial bon et
lee ont continué l'interview mensonge
vous êtes à combien de pétards par jour
15 le matin 10 le midi trois le soir là
c'est pas mensonge
est-ce que vous est ce que vous trouvez
ça bien de mentir
ouais j'adore c'est génial c'est jean
qui tient plus ou moins sans raison moi
mon métier génial de mentir ben on
essaye de voir si j'ai pas une moue
commencé sa toute façon balzacien
compléments capillaires uniquement alors
c'est pour ça je te demanderai de
toucher uniquement cette partie là je te
remercie toi comme bernard mais bref bon
une toute façon il faut qu'on vous
rendent à hollywood night
je remercie etienne je suis je te
remercie de nous avoir plus que l
héroïne hollywood night ce soir jack
vous pouvez le remarquer
m
pour elle cherche kalfon s'il vous plaît
pc un tout petit peu voilà la lumière
jean galant bouge pas je vous faire une
idée renommant sont justement comment
fait d'habitude à la télé vous êtes prêt
moustiques 8 vers la répondants montant
oui c'était difficile ça se regarde
l'air qui lie la 16e le le bon dieu sans
confession
est ce que vous êtes content que le pacs
a été votée je trouve ça honteux je
trouve que les [__] faut tous les tuer
des gens d'extrême droite moustiques
abrite toujours d'ailleurs je trouve que
on peut être homosexuel vous n'êtes pas
seul de déclarer
est-ce que vous avez été heureux est-ce
qu'ils étaient heureux benoît delépine
que la gaffe il est élu personnalité de
l'année aux sept d'or trouve souvent un
vrai qu'on ne faut que tu es aussi mais
c'est l'interview mensonge saint bernard
non mais moi je ne le pense pas du tout
ce que j'aime bien j'adore la gaga mon
meilleur ami mais qui sait plus votre
émission favorite du mensonge
est ce que vous trouvez que ppda les
journalistes oui bravant la pluie
l'incongru règle
ils arrivèrent de ses 1 400 bloqués non
oui ou c'est notre truc c'est la coke
si on a d'ailleurs là je me sens déjà
mince on n'en a pas mais c'est
l'interview mensonge avait justement
d'accord dans les clean mais c'est pas
possible de talent comme une bonne tête
pouvaient pas j'en ai bonne claque de
groland et des hollandais
non mais nous c'est non on est très
clair c'est marqué dessus c'est du vin
du hb et du vin nous excuser c'est
marqué dessus est pour vous la
dépénalisation de la centrale interview
mensonges en ce qui vous concerne je
suis pour une modification de la
législation puisque elle n'est pas
appliquée je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui
personne n'est poursuivi pour avoir fumé
du haschich en pratique dont
heureusement que je suis aujourd'hui
dans sa carcasse et si ça peut arriver
donc évidemment le principe de
l'interdiction
en soi peut-être compris mais en tous
les cas la pénalisation comme c'est le
cas à l'heure actuelle non appliquées
ouais là pas de sens
benoît delépine moustiques merci donc
vous a bien rendu votre bouquin la save
à eux donc alors voila voila voila je
veux non je n'ai absolument rien a
ajouté bowman a ajouté mme guigou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il me fascine à chaque fois donc comme
tu as menti on va te faire une interview
mensonge d'accord j'arrive pas vous
voyez philippe excusez-moi mendy moitié
ou c'est mieux ben alors donc
l'interview mensonge il faut répondre
sans dire la vérité on la vache
ouais est ce que vous pensez film gilda
ce qui est une bonne ambiance à canal
oui est ce que vous pensez philippe
gildas que votre émission actuelle est
un succès oui est-ce que jérôme bonaldi
vous étonne tous les jours oui est-ce qu
alain de greef a toujours deux
merveilleuses idées joker est-ce que
c'est pas un petit peu dommage qu'on
n'ait pas vu cette émission avec
florence belkacem équipe à dos
oui est ce que c'est vrai est ce que est
ce que vous vous utilisez est-ce que
vous c'est vrai que l'émission que de
faux j allais ruquier le samedi matin et
qui s'appelle un an de plus
est ce que c'est vrai que vous n'en
ratez pas une à la question est mal
formulé non et sinon vous êtes content
que lagaf et est élu personnalité de
l'année aux sept d'or oui est ce que
c'est vrai que tu me trouves tu es un
très grand projet je m'excuse j'ai pas
menti ah bon ouais t'as pas menti non
bon savoir que vous m est ce que c'est
vrai que vous ayez des cours à prendre
des micros rapport est-ce que vous est
ce que c'est vrai qu'avec maryse vous
fréquenter les boîtes échangistes
oui c'est là où il a échangé mari est ce
que c'est vrai que j'avais un sexe
énorme oui
c'est vrai vous fumez 15 pétards par
jour oui ok tu te rends compte
ouais nan 15 personnes gentilles
personnes oui alors c'est le fume pas
parce qu'elle dit que c'est pas bien de
fumer parce que ça empêche de bien
travailler ensuite à la jamaïque c'est
comme ça qu'elle soit 1,10 tous les cinq
ans c'est un autre moine ont tous les
trois tu veux dire que
travail c'est quand tu travailles c'est
bien pendant métis il faut qu'on laisse
le loisir aussi le loisir de travailler
bon peut rallumer les lumières serge
s'il vous plaît bien jean louis borloo
comme vous êtes avocat et homme
politique on va vous faire l'interview
mensonge en mousse pas
[Applaudissements]
il va bouger encore madden série shark à
bouger non j'ai la bouche c'est la
réponse que vous avez vous géré j'ai
bougé des yeux et se fait pas plaisir et
je donne tout ce que je voulais dire un
truc c'est que je me permets moi je vous
en prie le tas pour ça oui ce monsieur
je sais pas il parle non non c'est la
première fois que j'entends un homme
politique d'hier ces connards et ça ne
fait pas une politique
alors interview mensonge jean-louis
projet de près il faut répondre sans
dire la vérité sans dire la vérité d'un
entraînement pas bien entendu ma mère
qui va tout comprendre et ce que vous
croyez avoir un avenir politique il faut
que je dise linverse de la vérité un
mensonge
oui est-ce que vous pensez que berrou et
douste-blazy en avenir national
alors ils peuvent se pacser oui ouais
est ce que chirac est le meilleur
président qui ait eu la vème république
elle en est une autre jospin la gauche
morale
ouais est ce que vous trouvez ce qu'il
est entouré de gens honnêtes et
irréprochable aux notes
globalement oui euh non ça c'est bon je
me suis autant plantes et non bah vous
avez déjà frauder le fisc
non oui mais je suis
ils n'arrivent pas à mentir j'embrasse
existe les uns primaire qu'à l'air malin
c'est ainsi que manuel havrais pape
galère est-ce que vous avez déjà trompé
votre maîtresse
oui j'ai pas de maîtresse sautant est-ce
que vous fréquentez toujours les boîtes
échangistes
oui oui comment rick l oui vraiment oui
est-ce que vous pouvez toujours autour
de pétards avant d'aller à l'assemblée
nationale oui bon ben voilà il ya les
marocains au maroc d'accord bombe
attribué à mohamed si je fais plus du
maroc air et lumière commercial comme
vous êtes justement quelqu'un de sincère
je vais vous faire l'interview mensonge
on ne bouge pas par le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-paul nuit là j'ai réussi ferme
irisé méfie toi tu l'as fait dire quel
rigolo galerie elle peut pas s'empêcher
voilà à moi je surveille ce côté là tout
est surveillé l'autre côté ça a bougé
non un max gallo il ya un peu bouge ça
max gallo on recommence on recommande
j'aime pas balancer mais je les
soupçonne d'avoir les chouquettes et de
crispation
[Musique]
c'est compliqué bon gta l'interview
mensonge enrico c'est très compliqué
c'est à moi que ce gang est ce que vous
gagnez bien votre vie non je suis un
pauvre type venez donnez donnez donnez
donnez moi
donnez donnez ce que vous avez déjà
frauder le fisc
et oui mais qui n'a pas fraudé rififi
l'équipe laquelle j ai dit la vérité
c'est trop tard c'est pour rire
est ce que vous êtes toujours
catholiques intégristes toujours mais je
suis un dévot mais alors c'est une
fidèle tous les dimanches le shabbat
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes quand même toujours un peu
extrême droite un peu antisémite quand
même enrico non halal à ne me parlez pas
de ces gens là avec leur nez crochu et
tout ça et tout le pognon qui gagnait
toraya y allez retournez dans votre pays
et surtout pas en israël le pen il
allume le poste il sait pas si c'est dû
faire un vous vous trouvez comment
physiquement en ce moment un haricot
je suis très laid c'est le mensonge
mensonge mais voilà bah ouais vous
trouvez très bien en ce moment et
grossit non mais j'ai blanchi je parle
pas des régimes parce que c'est son gros
problème a fait sans problème c'est la
nuit dans le frigo le parler qui donnait
à l'huile d'olive
marisa slice est ce que vous fréquentez
toujours les bars par ron hubbard
américain toujours je suis tous les
soirs mois à tous les soirs tous les
soirs je fréquente ces boîtes tous les
soirs et je veux fumer le cigare et
c'est non si c'est ça je fume pas le
cigare vérité je fume des cigares c'est
lui est ce que vous êtes plutôt abricots
plutôt haschich ou plutôt en herbe
elle est dure celle là disons haschich
parce que chez nous on dit ça va ça
vient de ce mot là ça vient du mois
haschich ça veut dire que chercher ça
veut dire on aime bien voir la tête un
peu dans les nuages un ca entre deux
mondes artificiel vous êtes plutôt en
herbe en fait dans l'interview l'ancien
je suis et rb je suis achi dernière
question vous avez peur de mourir
ah oui j'ai très peur nourrir gilet
pare-balles en algérie pas gilet pare
balles
merci c'est ce que vous voulez qu'on
joue à un jeu à la chasse non non on va
jouer je suis très joueur et très
joueurs mais juin je suis un gagneur
alors on va faire un jeu qui s'appelle
l'interview mon change vous bougez pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
impeccable
[Applaudissements]
à redon à la saluer un homme j'essaye
d'instituer un rituel bon maxime gremetz
alors vous vous êtes un jeu qui
s'appelle interview mensonge vous
répondez sans dire la vérité
comme si vous étiez un homme politique
alors attaque attaque jeunesse pas faire
alors je vous pose une question et vous
me répondez en montant on est bien
d'accord
est ce que vous êtes toujours ultra
libérale oui plus que jamais ça vous
plaît j'ai formidable ultralibéralisme
de regarder des millions de pauvres des
profits labour formidable ce que vous
avez bien compris le jeu est ce que
c'est vrai que vous avez coucher pour
réussir
oui le doigt et je me couche jetable
c'est bien connu jospin lève le doigt je
me couche à l'assemblée vous faites un
maximum de fric en tant que membre du
parti que brosse formidable ouais je
sais plus quoi en faire
d'ailleurs je donne beaucoup aux bonnes
oeuvres je vais gérer
j'ai rencontré mon ami creton rey défend
les bonnes causes jouer daudet plein
d'argent
vous avez déjà frauder le fisc oui
souvent ils veulent un petit n'a pas
green n'a pas fraudé le fisc et vous le
si je vous pose la question on dirait
oui oui bah oui bien sûr mon sens est ce
que vous trompez toujours votre femme
tous les jours bah oui maintenant à la
chaise d'accord c'est vrai que vous avez
eu une aventure avec karen cheryl ah oui
tout à fait c'est et merveilles
il ya des boîtes échangistes habile
peut-être non non non rien
merci à lui bravo très bien interview
mensonge c'est dur un don non c'est pas
dur ram dites pas que c'est pas l'heure
de rire il faut apprendre à mentir ça
s'apprend où ça comme vous dites tassez
vous dites ah c'est la vérité vous
n'êtes pas tellement langue de bois
1 vous êtes assez franche du collier de
perles comme disait un journaliste on va
vous faire une interview mensonge on ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors l'interview mensonge c'est facile
il suffit de répondre sans dire la
vérité
entraînez-vous alors il faut mentir
mangement est ce que vous gagnez bien
votre vie oui je gagne bien ma vie je
gagne très bien ma vie je la gagne super
bien je gagne plus que les
fonctionnaires de la ville de paris a
fait d'accord avec votre mari beat
panafieu est-ce que vous avez un compte
commun vous mettez tout l'argent sur le
même compte où chacun à son compte à la
maison ou oui bien sûr nous avons un
tournus commun nous avons un compte
commun et alors nous on chambre à part
est-ce que vous avez déjà frauder le
fisc
oui j'ai beaucoup frauder le fisc je
comptais vous demandez des tuyaux là
juste en sortant de l'émission
françoise de panafieu est-ce que vous
avez déjà couché pour du boulot on va
c'est à dire que là comme on ne prête
qu'aux riches mille fois c'est à dire je
passe ma vie je me demande d'ailleurs
comment je suis en train d'assister ce
soir
bien bien cette bonne affaire nous
pensons alors je continue est ce que
vous avez déjà trompé dit je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure madame de turckheim vous
avez dit vous avez dit non attendez j'ai
dit non mais attendez c'était un
interview - 5 à la maison confiance et
des palaces jeu ce soir donc notre
division vous l'avait trompée j'ai
trompé dit oui bien sûr voilà en paix
bien vous êtes pas on a un pétard lg
vient de la côte bien alors dernière
chose les formidables dernière chose on
rallume la lumière de bord voilà non la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus vous
connaissiez pas bien la taxe tobin vous
avez j'ai approfondi d'accord vu un
petit cours avec madame arlette
laguiller les bords vous êtes vous êtes
toubib taxe tobin
je vais te dire je vais vous dire pardon
la taxe tobin c'est une phase iii vous
qui êtes aristocrate cela vous
intéressera la taxe tobin c'est une
façon de faire la révolution sans couper
de tête et sans faire couler de sang et
son boule hague
il suffirait que chaque sur chaque
transaction financière dans le monde
comprenne 0 1% ou 0 5% et sa dégagerait
chaque année 228 milliards de dollars et
ça permettrait d'éradiquer la pauvreté
c'est la révolution sans sont morts son
goulag son camp qui d'origine de sa
messieurs tobin qui est pas un hippie
c'est un prix nobel d'économie c'est un
américain prix nobel d'économie qui un
jour a mis ça au point mais le sevrage
il faut que tout le monde soit d'accord
le monde entier la france pourrait
commencer bien sûr mais il faut que le
monde entier sur l'accord donc si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez appeler
attaque dans le numéro s'écrit sur
l'écran je milite pour ça moi c'est une
grande cause pour laquelle j'ai envie de
militer en plus le vulgaire s'était pris
par biggar
bien bien merci françoise de panafieu le
pire est à venir
le pire est à venir thierry lhermitte
est ce que vous suggérez mentir oui bien
sûr moi pas du tout ça tombe bien je dis
toujours la vérité parce qu'on va faire
l'interview mensonge en la bouche
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des kadhafi c'est un bonheur cette
émission et d'eads a fist au mexique
c'est insensé j'ai reçu un email et au
mexique n'ont pas lui mais un débat fils
thomas van dyck des gens qui regardent
l'émission au mexique qui bouge pendant
le jingle et qui sans cette histoire
alors à l'époque de deux pasteurs
vous avez des relations homosexuelles et
gérard jugnot
bah oui enfin obligé de donald mais
c'est vrai que récemment c'est vrai que
récemment vous avez décidé de faire un
petit essai tous les deux à nouveau
ensemble
il veut pas voir mais voilà le problème
c'est qu'on veut pareil voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu je
te le dit gérard wey la caméra je te le
dis je suis encore là et je crois je
t'attendrai toute ma vie bien thierry
tail en continu dont vous avez fait
votre service militaire dans légion
étrangère
vous avez une aventure avec un sergent
un ancien de l'indo qui était le fils
naturel du général de gaulle ça ne s'est
pas beaucoup non effectivement ces
corridors
c'est quoi
et alors mais
quand on sait lire entre les lignes des
articles de fond on le comprend
effectivement il était beau monde est
chaud il sentait bon le sable chaud
alors au début d'histoire d'hésiter
gigolo pour payer les travaux
vous avez souffert de ça ça vous a
humilié nom et que je ne crache pas non
monsieur
gg souterrain gérant du tg rendu heureux
croyez moi vous êtes donné du bonheur
vous êtes un film porno le propos de
premiers films en face à un film porno
avec brigitte là et vous avez une
aventure de plusieurs mois avec elle et
elle dira elle dit vous quand elle parle
de vous elle dit il aurait pu être un
superbe reco siffredi là je peux pas
répondre à cette question c'est vous
avez déchets j'avais dessiné des fouets
oui là je ne peux même pas nombreux
merci brigitte à votre boîte échangiste
préféré à paris en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est pas tout à fait d'un dieu ça évite
thérèse arrêté à dakar et je connais
alors est là mais elle prend comment
votre aventure avec claire keim là
pendant le tournage du film le roman de
lui voilà il ya une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien cette fois mes chances
étaient quand même temps vous êtes
ensemble ces premiers chalets 25 où elle
s'aventure we will ses habitués bien sûr
y'a pas de problème
non non non non au camp est claire elle
supporte que vous aviez quand même temps
en temps dans la maison elle si c'est
plus dur pour elle les dimanches en
musique cet objectif est obligé d'aller
j'avais envie d'aller voir les enfants
et tout bascule comme ça tout ce qu'ils
m'ont dit sur bourbon thierry tu ailles
vous êtes un grand ami de jean marie le
pen s'est pas désolé un petit peu par la
disparition du front national du paysage
politique français sont ils se sont
cachés vraiment mais le débit
ils ont déconné et vraiment quand on a
des cantons et des beaux amis comme ça
ça se brouiller pour une histoire de cul
c'est ton père alex à nous dont vous
êtes le plus riche en fait des anciens
du splendid vous investissez beaucoup
dans les airs aux senteurs dans le nord
de l'europe et vous avez une spécialité
c'est la russe fait venir des camions de
russan fait déguster les slovènes ça
marche spécialisée dans le pays de l'est
vous j'avais des amis qui bêtement on a
mis en du gosse la vie qui vient de se
faire incarcérer mais très bêtement mais
il me prend fournissait c'était sympa
mais qu'est ce qu'elles ont le plus les
filles de l'est pourquoi voulez-vous me
fait tenir par camion par wagons entiers
sont sincères à l'association elle
compte pas besoin déclaré je voudrais
mourir comme elvis presley bourré de
tranquillisants bourré de sucreries en
train de sauter des lolitas vous
maintenez ça oui oui c'est une sorte
d'apothéose c'est vrai que devant votre
place vous essayer de chanter comme
elvis et tout ça c'est que pour moi et
non vraiment et les russes et les
lolitas alors même désir quand vous êtes
quelqu'un qui dit essayer de dire en
tous les cas la vérité je vais vous
faire une interview mensonge
blessé le principe de l'interview
mensonge hélas vous allez répondre sans
dire la vérité c'est les interviews
tiberi avant alors est-ce que vous avez
déjà détourné de l'argent public
non oui il faut dire oui pardon oui
c'est le je vous ai déjà frauder le fisc
oui souvent mélangés jamais fraudé le
fisc
est ce que vous regrettez que jean marie
le pen ait disparu du paysage conrad
français vous oui voilà est ce que vous
sentez proche de mitterrand quand vous
apprenez qu'il a été décoré de la
francisque par le maréchal pétain
et qui l'a gardé longtemps après la
guerre des liens d'amitié avec bousquet
non mais ni terran a été un résistant à
partir de 41 et il a vraiment pris des
risques il a innové en change les
revenus en france et donc je crois que
ceux qui veulent donner des leçons il
faut d'abord qu'ils regardent eux mêmes
elle a été la hauteur de leurs propres
engagements dans certains combats vous
arrivez pas mentir là j'ai du mal
parfois à lully arrivé bien pourtant
est ce que vous êtes toujours antisémite
harlem désir mais on peut pas répondre
jours c'est la première fois
ouais j'ai vu quand même lucides et
communisme expliqué que magna était un
général
quoique fort que je sais je vous écoute
alors est ce que vous êtes toujours
antisémite c'est impossible pour moi je
suis passé vous avez déjà couché pour du
boulot
bien sûr est ce que c'est vrai que vos
collaboratrice sont victimes de
harcèlement sexuel tous les jours ou
baiser sans capote vous toute façon
évidemment si vous fréquentez les boîtes
échangistes toujours vous souvenez et en
ce moment combien de semaines plus tard
par jour en ce moment le plaisir est là
on peut pas répondre par oui ou par non
il faut donner un chiffre
dis-toi faux chiffres puisque ces jeunes
interview mange et dort jamais plus de
2,3 à machine reconnaît se dit [__]
tomber il y aurait dix mois de moins 3
je partais est-ce que
vous êtes pour l'ecstasy en vente libre
et bien entendu il y maintenant on va
faire exercice un petit peu compliqué
souvent les hommes politiques car il
mieux que les autres sais pas pourquoi
ça s'appelle l'interview mensonges et
ont peu bougé dans le jingle six fois
[Musique]
est-ce que d'habitude on peut pas bouger
mais ce soir exceptionnellement comme
l'avait prévu on était sûr de pas arrivé
à le tenir donc on a changé la règle du
jeu tout à l'heure je veux lui faire
avaler un bouquin oui ça fait six fois
qu'il dit prévenu monsieur prévost alors
que je dis monsieur prévost je suis
marché du gros 100 km à l'est attention
pas de violence il vous auriez emmanueli
donc vous mentez 1
est ce que ça vous choque que des gens
qui ont bénéficié de l'école en france
des soins dans les hôpitaux
dès qu'il gagne un peu d'argent il
quitte la france pour aller vivre en
angleterre et payer leurs impôts en
angleterre ça ne me choque pas est ce
que vous comprenez que des gens qui
travaillent dans le froid avec des
masses dans des usines de poissons
surgelés demande à travailler 35 heures
vous trouvez ça normal vous non je
trouve pas ça normal
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
par exemple que la compagnie
d'assurances axa double les primes
d'assurance pour les handicapés à la
raison à la région
total qui utilisent des bateaux pourri
mais pas cher le sait le business après
tout où ils font déjà faire quoi pour
deux offres sont dans leur job
vous êtes d'accord vous que les prêts
dans les bibliothèques municipales
soient payants absolument et c'est cher
aux auteurs que deviendrait-il autrement
c'est pas grave qui soit pas lui
pourvu qu'ils soient bien payés c'est
scandaleux quand même que vous trouvez
pas donc les musées soit gratuit parce
que finalement c'est le contribuable qui
paye et puis je trouve ça permet pas aux
gens d'apprécier à leur juste valeur les
étapes que les tableaux qu'on leur
montre il faut quand même donner un peu
de soi même n'est ce pas voudrais pas
que fabius était un peu trop à gauche
quand même si
à part ça on va passer aux femmes
oui c'est facile vous êtes atteint par
le démon de midi
oui oui c'est l'interview m'en sors jb
oui oui vous êtes toujours avec l'abbé
échangiste oui j'avais parce que alors
est ce que vous savez que deux plus deux
à déménager ou gipi ya longtemps c'est
boulevard edgar quinet maintenant une
vue je connais le boulevard je connais
pas traîné mais je trouverais quand même
vous êtes quoi rouler vous avez de quoi
voulez un pétard évidemment pétards
début de soirée après je passe à autre
chose comme avec mes choix que vous
aviez arrêté la coca aurait aimé lui et
non non non non en attendant genre
d'armes on va faire une interview
mensonge je connaissais le principe
d'interviews mensonge il faut dire le
contraire 2 au contraire de la vérité
oui c'est pas c'est pas ça un complément
de vérité ou de le contraire de ce qu'on
pense enfin tout ce qu'on pensait pas ce
que vous pensez que vous pensez la
vérité bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vous déplacez toujours en limousine
avec des vitres fumées et puis des gens
qui vous allume comme ça vos cigarettes
ouais ouais pourquoi c'est parce que ça
fait chic ça fait chanter des airs vous
pensez que vous êtes une star et que
vous devez avoir tous ses attributs de
la star études c'est cela donne c'est
quoi votre voiture limousine votre la
merco sa 600 en vacances vous allez
toujours faire du tourisme sexuel en
thaïlande
vous avez déclaré c'est ma façon de
participer au développement économique
du pays
si j'ai dit ça je ne peux je ne peux pas
me je ne peux pas dire le contraire mais
la revue machin de nom je pourrais vous
partez seul à bangkok
pourquoi pas avec des amis vous êtes
misanthrope à ce point là exactement et
oui ça fait partie de plaisir que je ne
partage pas donc je vous fais des choses
tellement inavouables la bague que vous
pouvez pas partir c'est pas tellement
une voie puisque on peut en parler
souvent on parle de tout aucun problème
vous a beaucoup vu cet été à
saint-tropez avec valérie kaprisky après
mathilda may c'est une espèce de
spécialisation que vous avez comme ça
dans les va dire ça comme ça
ouais ouais ouais ça se passe bien avec
application car si alors question c'est
que vous êtes beaucoup moins actif
qu'avant s'est déclaré dans match j'ai
compris que c'est dans les yeux que ça
se passe comment ça se fait c'est l'âge
c'est les cheveux blancs c'est la
prostate ou alors c'est simplement sa
sérénité tout simplement je pense un peu
des quatre peut-être la prostate c'est
peut-être la prostate on voit beaucoup
avec la bande de michel drucker fait
beaucoup de sport avec la bande de
michel drucker tous les dix ans je fais
du vélo à à longchamp avant de manger
des pâtes au beurre avec delon et
belmondo sont comme celui-ci tombe et
vincent lindon bacri chabat enfin tous
vos copains pour pour la bande à drucker
celle soit non parce que je trouve
intellectuellement beaucoup plus faible
que la bande à laquelle vous faites
allusion
j'étais comme un drôle en définitive
moins jeunes que c'est plus que ce
fleuron auquel vous faites allusion
d'accord
vous vous avez une carrière honorable
finalement on s'est pas mal votre
carrière
merci ça j'ai fait que ça ne fait que
commencer ça ne fait commencer ben oui à
votre âge avec voix 42 ans dans le même
incessants en allemagne mais vous êtes
soutenus financièrement par votre frère
jean claude darmon l'honneur dans le
grand argentier du foot
énorme il va vous subventionnez comme ça
pendant des années tant que je tombe lui
demander tant que temps que j'arrive à
l'embrouillé a pas de problème est ce
que finalement c'est lui qui vous a
influencé de ce fait arrêter de vous
droguez on peut le dire je crois que
c'est ça fait une semaine alors vous
avez rien pris 24 heures c'est bien une
semaine c'est ce que j arrête un patch
anti héroïne voilà exaucé de vos pattes
c'est bien vous à gauche est d'accord le
crack juste dans le domaine
philosophique surtout en philosophie qui
est très intéressé par par nietzsche
vous êtes anice inter le surhomme
tout à fait je partage l'opinion mon ami
le qui n'y voyez c'est ça que vous êtes
le nietzschéen pour vous il ya des
surhommes et des sous-hommes 1 c'est
bien que ça le reste de la merde le
reste c'est de la merde vous dites alors
ça c'est très étonnant c'est la première
fois que je vois ça vous avez déclaré
stefan hell
vous avez déclaré j'aimerais mourir
comme presley pourquoi parce que ça a
duré longtemps parce qu'il était gros
plein d'eau plein d'alcool de la grèce
mais j'adore les sucreries
voilà si je peux mais tout fait en
bouffant je l'habille gaza
oui c'était la tanche france on joue
deux gendarmes en bouche pendant le
dinner
[Musique]
ça va alourdir en ardoise quoi voilà
tout donc interview mensonges de jacques
mellick qu'est-ce que vous êtes toujours
de droite
bien entendu c'est formidable et simon
bien alors il ya un autre maire qui a
des soucis en ce moment c'est tiberi est
ce que vous allez l'aider à c'est
évident ouais boulet mais beaucoup
tiberi achats d'or un type honnête a
profondément c'est pas le genre à faire
des faux électeurs et des trucs comme ça
regarde regardez le couple way un
rapport et xavière sa maîtresse âge à
400 milles est ce que vous trouvez pas
de mazac bdic convoi pu sarkozy si
souvent tabou est extraordinaire c'est
vous sentez prononçons oui je me sens
très proche de lui sur ses sur ses idées
et les sympathiques mais déjà trompé
votre femme vous l'avez déjà trop frais
peut-être que c'est quand vous faites un
tableau mensonge que vous servir en
songeant plus ml tu sais déjà que c'est
compliqué est ce que c'est vrai ce qu'on
raconte que vous êtes un des plus gros
clients des boîtes échangistes du nord
pas de calais hélas je dois le
reconnaître
ouais pourquoi vous dites est là c'est
agréable quand même nom il paraît vous y
prenez beaucoup de plaisir à beaucoup je
prends du plaisir comme le dirait via et
ses vacances tout seul en thaïlande cet
été ça s'est bien passé
ouais j'étais traite bien ouais ça
s'appelle alors ophélie winter
vous étiez avec ophélie winter en
thaïlande à pratiquer non à phuket non
dit non donc c'est vrai
alors chaque minute qu'est ce que c'est
vrai que vous avez arrêté de fumer des
cigarettes vous fait plus que de l'air
pur maintenant parce que les cigarettes
ça donne le cancer du ska p tard par
jour non oui au moins et pour relancer
l'agriculture dans le pas de calais vous
aller cultiver le chambre sa saison une
expérience ouais vous commencé à
présenter sur quelques hectares sur
quelques hectares très bien et ça ferait
du boulot à la place de testut quand tu
sera fermée alors dernière question
est-ce que vous avez menti durant cette
interview mensonges bien entendu
[Musique]
bravo parce que vous n'avez pas bougé
par le single mais j'ai bougé les yeux
normalement on doit même pas qu'il y ait
des cieux pas mal non mais moi j'ai
bougé les yeux en rythme de haut en bas
de droite tout le temps mais je vous ai
pas vus ben voilà c'est ça la force de
la révolte des rebelles l'appli qui m'a
pas vu quoi on va vous faire une
interview de mensonges rires ouais quand
vous allez mentir il faut que je manque
oui pourquoi pas parce que c'est une
interview mensonge
ah bon ça va être dur pour vous non bien
on va voir je sais pas j'ai déjà menti
aussi c'est vrai que vous avez une
fortune en fait est que vous avez
beaucoup de beaucoup d'argent qui est
placé en actions sur le marché
international alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
dire est ce que tu as dit mme wade nous
la vérité déjà tant que dira si son
corps à corps
vous êtes bourrés de bay away est ce que
est ce que vous battez les toujours en
limousine vitres fumées ou fait allumer
vos clubs par vos assistants
ah oui ah ben ça évidemment oui
et
et puis quand on fait ça aux hommes
politiques n'y a pas de problème ici est
qu'on prenne tout de suite des grands
fait ça avec un artiste c'est plus
compliqué oui il est toujours inscrit à
l'udf c'est quoi l'idée est à l'union et
l'union des deux avantages des fromagers
évidemment ouais bien sûr oui c'est vrai
jacques higelin que j'avais été obligé
d'arrêter de fumer des pétards pour
pouvoir vous inscrire à l'udf fumer des
pétards pour la je fume des pétards
alors arrêter à temps il ya deux
mensonges à faire un truc
contradictoires berry arrêter de fumer
des tickets oui je suis arrêtée mais les
buts
oui vous dire que non tu as paradis
fumer des pétards oui c'est ça oui j
arrete que lui dire est qu'elles
deviennent ils ont fumé cdf qui fument
des pétards ont fait le plein
voilà sur le plan sexuel vous souhaitez
toujours sur tout ce qui bouge non dit
oui les honduriens ont dit non à partir
non mais faut dire non sincérité c'est
ça voudra dire que tu sortes sur tout ce
qui bouge avec les gens qui fument des
pétards le dr
la différence c'est que nous dit
je sais ce que je vais arrêter de fumer
des pétards pour rentrer à l'edf
situation vous n'êtes quand vous faites
vous tourner en province à vous
fréquentez toujours beaucoup les boîtes
échangistes
oui eh bien tu me regardes pas continuer
c'est parce que j'ai pas de mélasse non
mais c'est quoi le plan la bastille
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette histoire
et cet été à saint-tropez avec la
pornostar non là tu dis non pourquoi
c'est comme ça les gens vont croire trop
compliqué rires oui non compliqué à
priori oui
ouais à la pornostar non oui l'argent
l'accord est retrouvée morte dans une
pinède à côté de saint tropez la fille
comment les malins c'est vraiment un
m'as vraiment un mauvais c'est vrai
manipulateur nez on l'a retrouvée morte
dans une pinède à connaître centraux
pinède un star dépens
bon dernière question jacques higelin
très très compliqué l'interview mensonge
aisément les hommes politiques ça passe
tout seul
vous avez déclaré j'aimerais mourir
comme elvis presley c'est-à-dire
intoxiqué au médicament aux sucreries
c'est vrai ça c'est dire oui oui oui
parce que dans le jeu oui oui j'ai rêvé
ça mais c'est quand même un truc de 1,2
les procès staliniens ou les déchirent
la côte est qui te pousse à tout ça les
à-côtés procès de moscou
il ya des finances ça c'est pour
enregistrer ses services et du séduisant
ça a duré glissement oui alors le
résultat de ça c'est quoi
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est un fait
je n'arrivais pas à monter on me c'est
un test un peu grossier quand même c'est
assez lourd
bah c'est vous qu'êtes lourd là avant
moi mais je n'arrivais pas à d'accord
pour la baston à quoi je démolis gros
tapis connaissez vous savez qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le djing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à siliana
c'est possible non c'est pas vous le
dire officiellement de boycotter ce
cérémonial stupide et injustifiée voilà
c'est ma position je devrais je me
souviendrai de droit
bien alors politiquement quel que soit
votre fidélité à vos engagements de
jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type dans
le programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate ça me va vous lui trouvez quoi
madelin ba hmad là je trouve qu'il a il
a un discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je vous le voyez
présent nettement je le vois à juste
titre leur candidat à la présidence de
la république et j'ai la ferme intention
et c'est parce que madelin a enlevé sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de manille c'est
là une sorte de mimétisme pelé mais
quand troisième millénaire qu'on
admirait canton estime quelqu'un dont on
a envie de lui ressembler c'est un peu
comme pour vous tirez vous vous êtes mis
au sport fait du vélo avec drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker c'est se passe comment ça se
passe pas bien pour lui parce qu'il a un
mal de chien à me suivre personne je
suis très très entraînés ça fait des
années et des années que je [__] les
sens du terme d'ailleurs et lui pour le
moment ils pédalent plutôt dans la
choucroute c'est à dire que il nous est
arrivé d'ailleurs il n'ya pas très
longtemps d'être filmé par ses petits
copains de la 2ème et c'était très
emmerdant parce que j'étais obligé de
j'étais obligé de pédaler dans le vide
pour qu'il puisse le rattraper le temps
passé dort beaucoup il dort énormément
il s'économise énormément et je ne sais
pas il ya quelques jours et quelques
sourires on mais peut-être que
finalement là alors il est beaucoup plus
âgée que moi drucker et donc c'est là où
au fond c'est la preuve à la différence
pour le téléthon avait fait 5 fois le
tour du périphérique en vélo 8 et
admiratif x 8 x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46
secondes 4/6
et alors
l'une des raisons de votre forme si
pierre aboutissent et que vous avez vous
allez laisser tomber la drogue d'une
façon à peu près complète sauf les
pétards mais enfin bon ouais une dizaine
de pétards par jour parce que ça
remplace cigarette on faisait arrêter
des cigarettes dont vous êtes obligés de
fumer des pétards à la spad pas disent
tout de même un badigeon déjà bien par
soeur du périphérique voilà la preuve et
vous avez retrouvé votre légendaire
énergie sexuelle qui a fait votre succès
faut bien le dire parce que bien
d'autres talents pierre mais ya pas que
ça non plus alors met d'ailleurs grâce à
dieu il y avait cette énergie sexuelle
sinon je serais absolument pas là où je
suis aujourd'hui voilà que pierre a
retrouvé en arrêtant la drogue son
énergie sexuelle on vous a beaucoup vu
cet été avec linda hardy à saint tropez
oui mais il ya d'autres corps pyndiah
vais voir morts il y avait nagui avec
une blonde décolorée arthur avec les
ondes et arditi avec bolloré brûlera
défi qui a démarré on sent l'amour à
mary bale donc c'est vraiment cool
à son honneur l'accord et quelle durée
c'est parce qu'il va jouer si vous
voulez au taf gymnase marie bell s'est
dit tiens alors oui marie marie marraine
belle n'est pas courant c'est la petite
oui mais là y aura de la laitue et la
marie d'elle on l'appelait huit c'est
joli gaston il a un autre dinosaure il
s'appelle mary bale voilà les cantons
enfant va grandir et qui va te dire papa
ya pas à cette pub sur le plateau que tu
vas faire quoi concrètement je vais
faire revenir
donc oui retournez-les en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout la tournée des boîtes
échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
que mr barbier m'avait dit que qu'au
fond sa clientèle son public on ne
fabrique qu'en province
et j'ai suivi ce conseil à la lettre et
c'est d'ailleurs blier lui-même qui
m'avait dit que je pouvais justement
profiter voilà l'avantagé des tournées
c'est sa fille voilà et donc ça fait une
bonne douzaine d'années maintenant que
je fais plus grand nombre de boîtes
échangistes vous donnerai des adresses
intéressera sûrement d'ailleurs un
excellent se connaître j'ai l'intention
d'éditer un guide safia le bio il ya le
guen et jean g dit il des boîtes
échangistes le arditi avec 1h hard way
vous êtes choqué beaucoup de monde pas
même avec votre mercedes vitres fumées
sur la roue et je vous fait allumer des
cigarettes par les assistants ne trouvez
pas que c'est un peu de tout mais vous
savez moi je vais vous dire quand on a
réussi après tout c'est ça ouais hein
quand on a du pognon
quand on a du vent et on sait bien dans
les clubs où ces maisons qu'à se
démerder pour faire les mêmes choses
voilà
on reconnait on reconnaît vraiment le
même ministre le choc
le libéral le libéral de choc
alors ben on va terminer avec la
littérature fait des lectures publiques
aussi dans les villes où vous vous allez
vous lisez du renaud camus vous lisez du
robert brasillach du nietzsche oui c'est
des jeux les jeux les découvert sur le
tard et je dois dire que j'ai eu tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture de ma
part très bon il celui là encore il ya
une parole importante à proférer
aujourd'hui il ya une pensée que qu'on
ne partage pas suffisamment et en
particulier dans les couches basses de
la société qu'ils ne disent pas comme
tout le monde le sait mais je voudrais
être le chantre font de cette parole
vous la tendance à atteindre et je ne
vois pas pour les élèves voulaient de
vos lectures de brasillach son remarqua
mais voilà il antisémitisme ça vous
choque plus du tout un fût un temps où
ça vous énervez maintenant vous vivez
avec bah qu'est ce que vous voulez nous
finalement c'est dans l'air du temps
alors après tout pourquoi pas hein
voilà
[Applaudissements]
en bouche marketing on ne bouge pas
pendant les guignols
voilà non mais je sais mais je n'avais
pas fini mais je voulais finir
maintenant c'est pas un souci non mais
je me disais un problème de ravaillac un
ravaillac 2000 par exemple si l'arrivée
et qui vous tuer thierry mois serait
bien à la merde
ce ne sera jamais pourquoi on ne bouge
pas voir en bas qui a essayé pourtant
laurent gaffié notoriété lors on va fier
a fait 6 et de ci de là et c'est
pourquoi pour qui et on ne l'a jamais
dit pour mes reins bush prévoit là on ne
saura jamais j'emporterai de secret dans
ma tombe comme l'endroit des matchs
parce qu'on n'a qu'une vie bah oui mais
moi personne ne soit non en fait je veux
dire la vérité rien il ya le secret est
enfermé dans mon coffre à la banque dans
une enveloppe scellée qu'on ouvrira à ma
mort alors une folle rumeur alors un
mais c'est vrai l'échalote son mais en
même temps c'est pour rigoler vous savez
que le public n'obéit qu'à moi vous avez
tous les mois des vannes criantes aussi
bien est ce que c'était est ce que le
fait que pour moi c'est non mais je
n'avais pas énervé que vos parents sont
blancs et que les votes sont noirs
mais ça vous fait rigoler baisser la
tension en change
ah oui faut dire quand on s'est vus faut
dire non à ces interviews mensonge pas
dire le contraire de la vérité
oui et vous ils sont noirs mais c'est
évident c'est ridicule et il avec
lorsque alain de greef vous a vu pour la
première fois elle nous a pas reconnus
qui nous a pas reconnus côté vous avez
vu pour la première fois que c'est
normal enfin c'est pas normal
par contre à vous avez exigé quoi dans
votre contrat avec canal+ nous ce qu'on
exigeait un parce qu'on s'en occupe pas
en fait un temps une mensonge un
véhicule seul clic de votre bureau vous
avez quoi incana la tectonique des
plaques
c'est à dire que c'est la faille de san
andreas est intéressant parce que la
tectonique des plaques on n'en parle pas
assez et ça se frotte comme ça et hop la
faille passe par canal exactement où les
scores des vacances vous les prenez ou
mensonge soussou bah ouais assez monsois
ouais parce que moi je reste chez moi
le calcul fait le calcul
soir dans les airs
fort et tués samedi
avec
et bonne brise des vies
vous êtes berne et ex publicité avait
remercié doux interview mon sens la
bouche pendant le single
c'est votre côté rebelle qui vous pousse
à pousser un bougé par un jingle non je
suis la rebelle je suis la récalcitrante
voir l'insurgé vous êtes ultra libéral
sur le plan au plan politique le très
proche d'alain madelin plus d'alain minc
en fait oui vous vous trouvez pas que ce
système ultra libéral est porteur de
violence sociale frédéric ah non pas du
tout voulait rien un bon le marché
s'autorégule bon il ya des licenciements
massifs quand on fait des bénéfices mais
c'est très bien c'est pour la santé des
entreprises
oui vous pensez en france et je les fais
des bénéfices doit licencier des gens en
prévision du jour où elle en fera plus
évidemment sinon leurs actionnaires
comment ils vivent
ouais il faut je crois que c'est très
important que que les financiers
puissent s'engraisser un petit peu sur
le dos de des ouvriers non face à saint
frédéric est ce que vous partagez la vie
de jacques séguéla qui pensent que la
pub est là pour apporter du rêve et du
bonheur aux gens
oui d'abord je rédigerai saluer
l'artiste parce que jacques séguéla
c'est un artiste c'est un poète c'est
des temps modernes et je pense que la
publicité elle apporte pas seulement du
bonheur elle elle est sincère quoi ouais
comme moi en ce moment
soyez sûr que ça vienne et comprennent
aussi que séguéla soit un artiste je
suis d'accord
[Musique]
alors y ait une chambre en pas frédéric
avec vous là votre limousine avec les
vitres fumées ses assistants qui sont
toujours là pour vous allumez les
cigarettes c'est vous ça vraiment oui
parce que je pense que le pognon c'est
bien moi je trouve que je vis pour ça et
j'ai envie de voilà j'ai envie d'avoir
une une existence
coupé du monde coupé de la réalité il
écrase et des autres bien sûr évidemment
bien sûr ça va de soi ouais et pourquoi
avoir laissé tomber l'ecstasy pour la
cocaïne saintrick jamais compris chez
vous ça ah non moi en fait j'ai jamais
pris ni l'un ni l'autre
ah oui ah non moi ça m'intéresse pas je
trouve que la drogue c'est pas bien ça
veut dire c'est c'est dangereux quoi il
faut jamais en prendre même un pétard
jamais fumé un pétard de ma vie ouais
quelle est la partie de votre corps que
vous préférez frédéric m'habite
compliqué là on se connaît bien mais y'a
un truc qui m'a toujours surprise chez
vous c'est cette incapacité à tromper la
mère de votre enfant ou même dans les
situations les plus propices aux vices
finalement comment vous faites interview
mensonge là-dessus lalalalalala voulait
vraiment coincé
non eh bien eh bien oui il la trompe
tout le temps je la trouve tout le temps
j'adore ça je pense qu'il faut se faire
sucer il faut il faut déjà que faciale
tous les soirs
c'est à bouchez vous les oreilles ma vie
le jacques faciale ou fait 80 pages là
dessus je recommence essayé comment
remercier la bienséance dans les aides
sociales alors on à la baronne vous
préférez bien entendu frédéric abbal
fidji maintenant je précise ma fille
excusez moi pour lui
intellectuellement je ne sais pas je me
sentirais plus à l'aise avec vous c'est
vrai ma femme combats seules des taux
des crédits
c'est bon vous plaisez à madame de
fontenay même de retenir c'est parce
qu'il ya un truc qui se passe c'est
marrant si je sais il fit aux nobles
c'est un peu lolita à l'envers c'est bon
frédéric alors comment expliquer ce
dégoût des boîtes échangistes qui vous
quittent
j'ai testé ça moi je trouve sa source à
honteux ces gens qui qui qui veulent se
met nu devant d'autres personnes
s'entassent et comme ça ça me dégoûte
ça me dégoûte je trouve que tu as sont
globalement le sexe me dégoûte joie
grâce à intéressant moi je hais les
vacances en thaïlande vous y allez
uniquement pour écrire vous c'est
marrant alors c'est vrai ouais budget de
développement économique du pays enfin
votre de votre discours est très social
mais c'est pour écrire et aussi manger
démangeait de m cette recherche de
sainteté que vous avez en vous ça vient
d'où
ça vient d'eux
du pape je crois que le pape c'est un
mec super il va être content mais c'est
l'interview mensonge donc il est
perturbé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elie wiesel quand je dis beigbeder
c'est un mec bien
oui oui mais il pas le seul à le dire je
vous dis galles dalaï lama il ya nelson
mandela un seul mandat il a dit si
l'humanité était composé de beigbeder le
monde serait meilleur
annoncé par vaclav havel qui a dit ça
aussi je dînais avec kofi annan et
boutros boutros ghali et ils me disent
frédéric ce que vous faites pour pour
l'humanité nous fait chialer de bonheur
et moi je devrais dussollier comme vous
êtes un mec honnête très très zone est
un loup car le provincial pas showbiz du
tout je vais vous faire une interview
mensonge quand le cheval
[Rires]
pendant le génial c'est bien vous n'êtes
pas bougé c'est parfait vous voulez
toujours en limousine avec les vitres
fumées
oui j'adore ça tous les matins quand
j'accompagne mes enfants à l'école
j'aime bien arriver par l'école et c'est
vrai que c'est allé beaucoup ça c'est
vrai c'est une on aime bien voir les
acteurs de cinéma reid en limousine et
vous avez des assistants qui vous allume
vos cigarettes sur les plâtres coup j'en
ai beaucoup je change souvent est-ce que
non mais c'est vrai ces essais c'est
difficile de supporter de la vie
quotidienne d'un acteur donc un bien il
faut pas s'emmerder exercice gérant tous
les jours et assistants des assistants
préfère oui ah oui on vous a beaucoup vu
à saint tropez cet été avec arthur avec
carlos avec colin roubaix avec nagui
zetas il était avec eux oui vous avez
déclaré en parlant de ses vacances là
enfin je revis mais vouloir trouver quoi
c'est à dire que ils ont ils ont des
bateaux énorme ça ça m'a permis grâce à
eux d'éviter loana
donc il ya longtemps que vous avez
arrêté l'héroïne la cocaïne à plusieurs
années non à taux courants ouais
quelquefois j'aimerais away aujourd'hui
fumer quand même pétards par jour bah ça
dépend pour l'émission l'a pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup roulé un parce que il a du
mal il pourquoi tu me regardes donc on
rencontre souvent avec deux jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines à des collègues
dk oui dans les premiers commentaires
votre épouse accept that très facilement
j'ai l'impression non elle est pour
ouais
parce que
mais le sais que je reviendrai toute
façon et valorise à d'accord oui ça se
passe bien c'est un couple moderne
je suis perdue mois là il ya un truc que
je comprends pas c'est cette passion des
clubs échangistes châteaubriant je ne
peux pas aller dans un club échangiste
on vous voir comme l'a dit titoff la
dernière fois ouais c'est pour
rencontrer des animateurs télé façon
thématique
on va continuer sur la vie privée dany
boon on va vous faire une interview
mensonge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un truc que je comprends pas chez vous
c'est pourquoi cette envie comme ça vous
avez absolument irrépressible de sauter
sur tout ce qui bouge c'est dû à quoi
c'est dû
oui parce que j'aime bien les c'est
ouvrir tout ce qui bouge
quel que soit le même pas que des femmes
voilées c'est vrai et c'est depuis tout
petit comme c'est parce que j'ai vécu je
t'ai élevé avec un chien et un mâle à
malabo très beau labrador de grande
taille
et puis c'est une liaison très peu de
temps
1° et depuis je me manque c'est que les
filles les filles 6e soirée n'étaient
pas rassurés de savoir que vous veniez
valérie la maquilleuse la dernière fois
la wii et voulait pas aller où je veux
détruire lui rendre judith elle supporte
comme ça que vous la trompiez à tout
bout de champ elle accepte ça elle adore
elle elle dit vas-y continue ce
formidable
ouais c'est là c'est ta voix mais lui en
souffrir quand même non pas du tout non
non parce qu'elle fait pareil qui peut
arrêter les boîtes échangistes quand
même non j'ai arrêté
oui et non j'y vais je veux boire des
verres et puis des gens me touche faut
dire dany boon que vous avez un sexe
énorme tout petit minuscule
ah ça c'est très étonnant et je m'en
suis rendu compte bêtement on l'a dit
quelqu'un regardez mon sexe dans des
genres ou qu'est-ce que tu es loin et il
m'a vu à nantes est doublé
à un moment vous avez essayé de
remplacer le sexe par la drogue oui
appris beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'héroïne crochet cocaïne et là j'ai
complètement arrêté
ouais parce que je
parce que j'avais appelé la police quand
on dit leur venaient en croyant que
c'était de l'anthrax et
c'est du coup je me suis fait gauler et
maintenance et des manques je je prends
de l'anthrax maintenant faut dire qu'il
vous faut beaucoup d'argent un dany boon
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement dépensier
je dépense a énormément de l'argent des
autres
ouais c'est ça le problème c'est que les
gens s'en rendent compte benoît 150
mètres carrés rue de la pompe
trois cent cinquante mille francs par
mois par jour 800 mètres carrés rue de
la pompe deux mercedes 600 oui j'en ai
jamais oui plusieurs couleurs tout ça
même puisque et alors ces espèces de
goût du luxe comme ça si vous avez deux
assistants qui vous allumez vos péta
toute la journée
oui en effet d'une assistante os
ils font comme ça avec des judith à
cette baby sitter cette baisse est là en
un an après une huitième pour s'occuper
des châteaux une par jour de la semaine
c'est incroyable c'est vrai avec qui je
vais au club d'échangistes pour boire
des verres on est d'un seul coup des
gens nous touche t elle bientôt quand
même puis des trois mille balles au
téléthon c'est sympa j'ai appelé j'ai
fait une promesse et j'ai rien en retard
ouais vous êtes du côté des possédants
maintenant ah ça y est la fête d'été
berisha j'adore j'adore un irish connaît
des ministres et tout ça hein vous avez
à droite maintenant c'est franchement
même limite extrême droite
ouais bah oui votre est vous l'avez
déclaré votre rêve c'est un madelin qui
serait plus à droite ou un le pen plus
moderne plus moderne et mieux coiffée
[Rires]
plus personne ne veut vous donner son
numéro de portable
non mais j'ai joué par contre je leur
prends leur portable à la place je vais
pas changer un petit peu de latitude lan
on voudrait pas être un peu plus
sympathique avec les gens je t'emmerde
non je sais pas vous apprendre je suis
pas la solidarité la tolérance la
compassion je pas des valeurs un peu
plus humaniste non gg toutes ses valeurs
sans au bac en jeu
quand j'écrase quelqu'un je m'arrête
maintenant et si on vous croiser avec
l'arrêt on vous écrase si vous êtes
désormais comédien fait que la grande
ville et dienville choix qui vous le
dirai l'art de la comédie c'est l'art de
mentir
nous allons donc faire une interview
mensonge c'est très compliqué vous devez
répondre steevy exactement le contraire
de ce que vous pensez un acteur d'accord
il ya du piège oui je sors il ya du pied
comment ça se passe avec l'udc est
plutôt très mal comment très très mal
c'est la cata tous les soirs bon il a
compris le principe pour déjà une chose
faite on regarde ça va tomber la même
stevie est ce que vous avez été obligé
de coucher pour avoir le rôle
oui j'ai couché par avoir ces rollin
avec ma main droite avec qui avec ma
main droite avec sa maman qui dit bono
sexuelle stevie ça vous fait quoi que
des gens payent plus de 40 euros pour
venir vous voir sur la scène d'un
théâtre ça je m'en contrefous un mot
rien à [__] chacun sa bourse
stevie imaginer qu'un jour vous marier
que vous ayez des enfants et que votre
fils viennent vous voir et vous annonce
qu'il est hétérosexuel vous réagiriez
comment très mal très mal
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait l'amour
et bourrique et stevie visite a fait la
bouffe à vue de briller enfin en tout
cas elle est à côté de moi à michel
demande qui est bourrique et michel
michel vous expliquer qu'ils évoquaient
alors bourrique et c'est une petite
tenue sur fond de grosses menu ce que
j'ai des plus l'âge de 6 ans décidée au
départ c'est marrant parce qu'il est
bien il est pratiquement plus connu que
moi vous riquez à chaque fois peut-être
pas d'hier
alors comment va vous dis ça c'est là
c'est le truc car comment va vous sur
des bonheurs steevy avez-vous menti au
cours de cette interview
non le mystère c'est bien ça mais il ya
une interview beaucoup mieux pour vous
que vous fait à chaque fois d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un grand menteur devant
l'éternel dit l'interview mensonge
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rarement vous êtes contents d'être
là je me sens un peu chez les messieurs
c'est sympa la promo c'est extrêmement
sympathique vous vous teniez les cheveux
là j'ai vu ce qu'on a à a
c'est pour faire c'est pour faire plus
jeunes ou pour faire plus vieux sénile
omnium pour montrer que j'ai des cheveux
surtout que vous vous trouvez comment
physiquement je me trouve
extraordinairement beau d'un charisme
un qui dépassent l'entendement d'une
intelligence nettement supérieur à la
moyenne
comme je suis en train de vous le
prouver depuis à peu près 20 minutes
alors concernant le sexe j'ai rarement
vous avez déclaré parce que bon on sait
que tu es un petit le moins actif que
certaines époques
vous savez des cotons l'interdire aux
anges
j'ai compris que c'est dans les yeux que
ça se passe oui c'est dans les yeux que
ça se passe c'est passé pas plus beau
l'amour platonique
alors concernant la mort vous avez
déclaré j'aimerais mourir comme elvis
presley plein de tranquillisants et de
sucreries et non pas le contraire
voilà ce qu'il veut rien dire non plus
c'est fou quand en matinée
[Applaudissements]
s
mais tu t'es plutôt bien monté
[Musique]
charlotte interview mensonge donc
turckheim après vos premières
expériences enfantine aujourd'hui vous
avez des expériences homosexuelles de
façon très régulière très très très
régulière et oui les jours ah oui
toucher tous les jeux oui j'adore ça
dans les partouzes et plus du tout
coincé comme à l'âge mais parce que j'en
organise maintenant j'en avais gagné
oui je sais ça chez moi les têtards
aussi il n'y a plus du tout de problème
comme la première fois vous saviez pas
s'il est le fumé ou pas oh ben non parce
que maintenant c'est pas pareil
maintenant on en plante dans le jardin
aussi si vous voulez donc on ne sait pas
mauvaise mais on sait pas trop ce qui
s'est passé alors nous on a un petit peu
bosser vous travaillez en fait là bas
dans un bar sur les ramblas
mais sinon c'est bar de nuit sur les
remplace votre réputation vous le savez
là bas n'est plus à faire on vous
appelez lolo tu as le latin oui
absolument
ça va me dire un truc là d'amateurs de
letat à barcella remplacent je me
souviens plus tout à fait la drees mais
c'est dans le christ est facile à
trouver
c'est dans le bas dans le bar la taverne
molotov c'est très très connu et
personne ne sait ici sa finale mais non
non non non non il ya trois ans quand
même un oui ça durait trois ans et
pourtant c'était un bach magnificat et
et j'avoue plaisir ah oui j'adorerais ça
j'adore et oui vous étiez venus
d'ailleurs vous même êtes appelés
charlotte de turnhout a déplu
c
le meilleur voilà une histoire en plus
un couac
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je tenais a été refait en fait je
n'ai pas du tout on est comme ça au
départ devient petit les parisiens c'est
bien j'avais année j'irai j'avais un
années que je trouvais ce qu'ils voient
la gym les ai pas beaucoup et j'ai fait
un coup bon ce n'est pas ça n'a pas tout
à fait réussi ça n'a pas tout à fait
réussi mais finalement vous regrettez
pas d'avoir fait refaire comme ça non
certains jours et coûté non cette année
je vais faire les oreilles aussi parce
qu'évidemment je les trouve bien je me
demande s'il ne serait pas mieux un peu
plus comme ça vous étonne beaucoup tout
ça j'ai fait que ces agressions
également il ya eu beaucoup d'histoires
racontées sur vos origines
aristocratiques en fait c'est pas vrai
du tout qui s'appelait charles autres m
oui c'est gras schéma au huitième mais
voilà arrêté cours chez svp
voilà exactement j'habite à la courneuve
je suis né à quoi jacques huot je sais
que c'est drôle parce que c'est vrai ce
que je vous dis quoi raconter des trucs
le premier rôle que joue et c'est au
café de la gare
j'ai joué une marchande de fromages dont
je parle comme ça et tu t'arrêtes tu
dégages et tous et j'étais plus jeune et
plus par année un agent qui m'a dit en
fait je voulais féliciter attend le
pseudo tu t'es pris c'est absolument
génial je dis commencé à medibat
s'appelait anne charlotte de turckheim
c'est quand même c'est quand même gros
pensé que c'était un pseudo
sur france 2
4 x 4
elle danse
et on va faire une cave you man sens
[Musique]
mais principe est simple steevy doit
répondre en mentant alors y en a pour
qui ça serait pas difficile ici bien sûr
un mais pour vous c'est un petit peu
compliqué vous êtes tellement pur mon
petit cochon stevie ça se passe comment
avec ruquier très très mal est fait
souffrir
donc ça veut dire que ça va très bien
non là où tu as choisi pourquoi alors
inquiet pour mon corps
a lors que tu aimes son humour ou alors
là pas dit cela je crois que c'est pas
un monstre et 10 mois et stevie tu crois
que tu auras un molière un jour oui je
pense tu sais qui c'est molière bien sûr
pas du tout
j'ai dit tu sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
rumeurs ont couru sur toi non à 6-6 oui
non mais si un jour ton fils tu annoncé
qu'il est hétérosexuel tu réagirais
comment j'aurais pas de fils steve tu
m'aimes pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on va faire si j'ai menti on
va lui faire une interview mensonge
interdit non sens
luis fernandez serait très facile pour
vous il suffit de mentir et je pense que
quand on a été entraîneur du psg c'est
pas difficile
d'accord mais depuis que vous êtes
partie le psg a gagné la coupe de france
et a fait deuxième du championnat est ce
que ça vous fait plaisir luis de voir
ses résultats
oui vous l'avez trouvé comment le jeu du
psg cette année
très bon avec vous à la tête de l'équipe
est ce que le psg aurait fait mieux
non vous êtes malheureux d'avoir dû
quitter paris luis oui vous pensez quoi
de votre successeur qui devient que du
bien saman doctor away
c'est vrai qu'au psg il ya plus
d'entraîneuse que l'entraîneur oui
est-ce que d'après vous le psg peut être
champion de france l'an prochain
non quand vous avez annoncé au jdd que
vous aviez un plan pour reprendre le psg
c'est un mensonge
non vous raconter beaucoup de conneries
quand même ça m'arrive souvent mais là
tu mens pas vous vous sentez responsable
de l'échec avec ronaldinho oui vous
n'avez jamais eu envie de vous excuser
auprès des supporters du psg oui pensez
quoi des fachos du parc sens un pas vrai
les sens après des congés
ça vous dirait un jour de devenir
entraîneur l'équipe de france oui notre
f&c de retourner au parc des princes
pour chanter non vous êtes content
d'être venu ce soir
non non ça ne va pas on va pas revenir
comme dans chaque émission de télévision
sur vos exploits conjugaux et extra
conjugaux parce que ça a déjà été
beaucoup fait dis moi je préfère un je
préfère en vous l'artiste que le que le
mari machine rouge et quatre femmes je
suis heureux j'ai trois petits bergers
la maman belge et les quatre pays les
trois petits bout'choux et la maman
quand même mais je suis un papa heureux
à la
ah on va faire une interview mensonge
alors vous savez comment c'est
l'interview mensonge vous répondez
linverse de la vérité vous montez khaled
interviewant sens alors khaled comment
ça va pas bien
vous êtes content d'être ici ce soir
non c'est vous fait quel âge maintenant
11 ans ça fait c'est vrai parce que vous
avez vous été le 29 février
oui et j'ai désormais 11 ans parce que
je le dis parce que cette année cgc
s'étaient mal et en 2012 avait eu 10 ans
est ce que c'est vrai rêve est que vous
porter la moustache en hommage à francis
cabrel
oui ou à saddam hussein oui c'est vrai
que j'allais vous teindre en blonde
oui vous avez grossi la non un petit peu
c'est vrai que vous êtes mis à manger du
porc maintenant oui grave c'est surtout
le marcassin
et et du bacon d'un club sandwich en
haleine vous allez arrêter de boire
non définitivement
ça fait huit ans maintenant 8 ans vous
avez arrêté ma dernière course était l 2
3 soleil mais dakar voilà c'est que
c'est l'interview mensonge là maintenant
je vois toujours je suis pas je pense
qu'il ya pas mal à se faire plaisir si
le suivent dur alors là tant il est
comment votre nouveau disque là n'est
pas dire du tout vous en êtes fier du
tout vous pensez être le meilleur
chanteur de raï du monde aujourd'hui
non
l'objectif de jennifer de la star ac
voulait mais beaucoup vous avez tous ses
disques d'or grave
cheb mami vous l'aimez bien mon dieu que
je les adore et faudel vous le trouvez
comment va pas bien pas bien du tout pas
bien du tout marc olivier fogiel vous
l'aimez bien à lui je lui ai dit ce
grave lui
senna benoit de la télévision vous
préférez son émission la mienne sans
émission vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui
radel non c'est vrai que vous êtes un
grand b heures oui vous aimez votre
femme khaled non vous l'avait déjà
trompée plusieurs fois plusieurs fois
vous êtes quand on est devenu ce soir là
non vous allez mentir la whey vous avez
mentir je sais pas faire moi ça va voir
comment ça va aller nul n'en sait plus à
quoi tendent et non pas par la santé le
reste mais c'est comme fred astaire et
ginger rogers quoi c'est quand vous êtes
obligés de vous retrouver c'est vrai
mais on fait ça pour l'argent
ouais ça vous plaît de faire la promo
saad et moi j'aime pas du tout au rien
dire ce mensonge mais moi ça me fait
tout seul c'est ça m'embête un peu
parfois ça dépend ouais il est bien ce
dvd l'intégrale 2
c'est une merde comment taquet survêt
remonter mais c'est une amie
anonyme avant des croix il faut
l'acheter pour noël ceux qui n'en ont
pas non non non tas d'autres trucs à
acheter un achète le dvd de baffin là à
dire des conneries comme ça on risque de
vraiment un outil la promo je vous le
dis continuez oui mais oui mais il peut
dire aussi te met à poil se mettra pas
pour des seuils
voilà jamais je me met à poil moi mais
ça n'aura pas coupé
j'adore laurent gerra
[Musique]
on va faire une interview mensonge tu
connais tu veux le principe doit mentir
voilà c'est pas compliqué comment ça va
co et bah écoute ça va super bien
ouais t'es content d'être ici ce soir
sans franchement je me fais chier grave
et ça me saoule de talent cette séquelle
âge maintenant écoute un bon 22
ouais là ils voulaient demain tagro
aussi un peu non d'abord ça me fait très
plaisir ce que tu me dis et non je pense
que j'ai pas mal mais grid 1 ou 2 kg 1
ouais tu dois beaucoup à bataille et
fontaine
que dalle je trouve que ce sont des gros
cons tu es fier de travailler avec eux
écoute je vomis chaque matin mais
beaucoup un jeu je suis beaucoup
beaucoup tu arriveras pas me faire dire
des saloperies que tf1 ça se passe bien
écoute on se défonce la gueule tous les
matins tous les matins on s'insultait
tout avec les patrons de tf1 c'est une
affaire d'amitié avant tout non non
c'est une affaire de coucheries c'est
parce que je suis le fils d diène et il
ya eu des rapports plus haut entre nous
la méthode cauet tu trouve ça original
comme concept deslongchamps je trouve
que je t'ai tour pompe et ça c'est pas
d'interview manceau mais si tu as ton
carnet de chèques d'écrire je vais
aborder d'ailleurs chinois doublé pour
les autres filets des poutres parce que
je voudrais devenir le reste du décor
agréé miel vous pouvez la fin de l'année
je te donne un fini la façade époux
nicolon jamais colonnes corinthiennes
j'appelle ça des poutres
la bolivie en même temps dis moi il ya
quand même des interviews un peu qui
ressemble un peu à celle de tout le
monde en parle des fois écoute
franchement non jamais oh oui je suis
très content j'ai un avantage je
n'arrive même pas à le suivre
quand même tu tombes à vous glacer le
meilleur animateur de la tête après
quand je vous aime à le dire mais c'est
vrai que je suis mauvais ouais bon
esprit il est édenté sartine bloque les
griffes
comment jamais une interview qui
ressemble aux miennes les départs et tu
as remarqué que j'ai jamais fait de
scandale à toi suite envoyé une lettre
où une fois mais après j'ai abandonné
bon we meet avait tout mis dedans tu as
les pendouiller 2
avec moi tu alors elle il avait dit que
je répond péter hauteur et qu'il y avait
des trucs dans ton émission qui était
dans la mienne voilà là c'est plutôt des
trucs dans ton émission mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas su quoi répondre et d'ailleurs
ce que je comprends bien n'ont pas
envoyé un chèque je peux maintenant on
n'est pas ce que parce que d'abord tu as
peut-être paf tu as peut-être pas tort
vu que tu fais de la tna mais tant que
tu fais de la télé depuis avant moi vu
que georgette pas cité de date mais vu
que quand j'étais petit je regardais ça
c'est des meilleurs jours iman que
j'étais fan nan mais je ne manque plus
que j'étais fan de lunettes pas pour
nuits blanches que j'aimais double jeu
revient à l'antenne on voit bien qu'on
n'a pas été nombreux à aimer mais moi
j'aime et et les zèbres
mais alors il ya un truc que je
comprends pas un midi thé tech et daphné
roulier tu m'as pas cité une seule fois
et des chemises jaunes pays basque ainsi
je cite parce que si je cite tout le
monde ça fait léger qu un doute parce
que j'ai cités qui j'ai cité foucault un
statut et admirait beaucoup de rigueur
mais veut dire sébastien mais en plus tu
sais que tu me pique mes idées mais
j'existe mais je te piquent pas tes
idées je trouve juste que je franchement
je jure que c'est vrai c'est un hommage
franchement quand on fait un hommage
chaque semaine à tyr ardisson non mais
franchement stupide tous je n'ai pas
répondu à ta lettre mais je te jure
qu'on t'a rien impliqué d'accord et je
te promets que si j'enlève les arguments
sont là je te les rendrait ici je te les
amène je te jure d'accord fait le studio
de la méthode cauet je te prends le pari
si je viens tu as mené les colonnes donc
on enlève derrière mais parce que moi
perso j'en peux plus citoyen vaches
meuglent j'adore donc je te les
ramènerait quelles sont les émissions
que tu regardes en ce moment pas
beaucoup je dois te regarde et toi
c'est obligé en même temps non assise
pour trouver des idées non non ouais il
paraît que tu es un grand b heures c'est
vrai écoute non et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu